- Eric's outfits, season one, season two
led an emotional journal through fashion.
(upbeat percussive music)
I am gonna take you through three outfits
that I feel best describe Eric's journey
throughout season one.
So this shirt, we see, it's the shirt
that he's wearing the first
time he meets Maeve Wiley.
And I think at this point,
Eric is like very much trying
to impress the world.
He's trying a little bit too hard.
I mean, he actually ends
up coming into school
with his buttons done up wrong
and tries to make up like some
new craze called norm-core,
which is not a thing.
It's a new look.
It's like norm-core.
This outfit we see when
Eric is kinda going
through a tough time and he's
trying to rebuild himself.
This is sad Eric. (laughs)
After the journey that he's gone on.
But we see him emerge.
And he goes back to church
and gets accepted back
into church, into the community.
And bam, comes through with this,
with the Kentai, the Kentai suit, fitted.
I just loved it because I am Rwandan,
so I have African heritage.
Felt nice the day of filming
to kind of just stand there
on the Netflix set and
stand there unashamedly.
I would say this is like
the piece de resistance.
Snatched at the waist, gave
enough room for the cakes.
From norm-core all the way
to the African butterfly,
this is the emotional
journey of Eric season one.
(groovy music)
Eric is a bit of a ho this season.
He's got a couple men that
he's deciding between.
Yeah, one of them
is a French sophisticated
something-something.
So Eric gets the bright idea to come in
with a scarf. (laughs)
So he's got this little
scarf, and this is the scarf
he uses to find his man.
You wanna find a man, get a nice scarf.
He goes camping with Remi and Otis.
This is what he wears to a campsite.
So obviously, Eric has
never been camping before.
And he turns it into a fashion parade.
And with these and some
espadrilles, it gets very wet.
Now, this suit is what
he wears to Otis's party.
And in season two, we see Eric,
he comes a lot more into himself.
He's being a lot more bold
with his fashion choices,
as we can tell.
I think Rahim's had a bit of
a like, cool influence on him.
This is an extension of the leopard print
that we see in season one.
And obviously, it's
just a lot more full-on
'cause Eric is a lot
more full-on this year.
Who doesn't want a fur,
leopard print track suit?
(laughs) It's a leopard
track suit, enough said.